today on hello world we are sticking
close to home for once uh we're gonna
travel virtually down the road to
stanford university
where there's a research lab that is
doing some really cutting edge
work around ai technology video analysis
and video manipulation a group of
researchers there have done
some projects in things ranging from
creating
fake tennis players versions of roger
federer
and serena williams they can play
matches against each other
and they're also doing this crazy
analysis of cable news where they've had
an ai watch 10
000 something hours of cable tv news
and find out which topics dominate
who's getting the most air time between
people like trump and biden and so it's
just it's sort of these fascinating
applications of the the cutting edge of
where ai and video meet
some of it i think will blow your mind a
bit and raise
some difficult questions and so with
that let's head off
to stanford university
most generally you know i'm a professor
of computer graphics and so
my students and myself and colleagues
like creating
new interactive experiences that were
never possible before that's sort of our
our mission what makes us tick i was on
twitter
one day and i'm just scrolling through
and i'm a
tennis nerd and so i i caught a video of
this thing of roger federer playing
against himself at wimbledon um and
and that obviously caught my attention
since that's kind of impossible
and and you know so i started digging
into it and i saw this is based on on
some
video analysis and and you know ai
technology that you guys
have been working on a lot of us in the
world right now are really interested in
different forms of generating analyzing
or manipulating video
and so i actually think it was an idea
for my colleague he said hey you should
you should take all this broadcast
sports video that's around and make a
really cool
video game out of it yeah and just to
just
to sort of break it down and you tell me
if i i'm like understanding this right
but you
you feed your systems all of this video
just the raw video of these matches
being played each player that you're
focused on you're learning their
the style of play what shots they're
likely to hit
we took two ideas that are out there in
the real world
we took sports analytics which all the
leagues are doing
all the time and that they're analyzing
video and then we took
a very basic idea from computer graphics
circa
2000 which is if you want a character to
do something
record them doing many things and then
mix and match
a bunch of little video clips together
and we did
use a number of modern deep learning
techniques
to really fill in some of the gaps i
mean obviously
like deep fakes are a big concern
with with modern ai are there you know
legit
i don't know concerns that could arise
from something like this i think there
are absolutely always legitimate
concerns
but a lot of what we did was based on
technology that existed
15 20 years ago and and i agree that
there's an inflection point you know
when it starts looking real
very realistic there's great power that
that comes with that
but it is not a new thing yeah
for a while you're like oh wow this is
roger federer hitting the ball and then
and then every now and then you're like
oh it moves
kind of a little weird i don't know if
it's like glitchy is the right word
but then at the same time i was like you
know i play
tennis video games and and there was a
realism
to it that you don't see in a lot of
those games
you could see that this is this is like
maybe the future of where this
stuff is going it's like i could
actually play a simulated
roger federer i mean absolutely the next
step going forward is
is working with with folks that can give
us access to a lot more video
because we did what we showed with only
two
or three matches from both of these
players if you gave us a much bigger
database
and the next set of techniques i believe
we can you know we can generate a very
compelling visual experience
you guys do a variety of different
projects over there and
you also have this this project where
you've done this really broad
analysis of cable news
looking at both what is said by
analyzing
transcripts and also who is who is
saying it who's on tv the most between
men and women different pundits you know
different people in the news like trump
and biden obviously
we're taking an extremely large corpus
of video we have
almost 24 7 broadcasts of cnn msnbc and
fox news since
2010. so we have transcripts and we have
video for all of those it's provided by
the internet archive
and and what we've done is we've
basically turned it into an enormous
library we've indexed it and we allow
the public to search
those transcripts as well as who is on
screen
and so we're really excited to see how
if we give the public whether that be
media watchdogs whether that be
journalists whether it be
scholars or hobbyists the ability to
essentially search this library of who
and what was on the news
we think that some some very positive
things might happen in terms of
understanding what gets presented
who gets the opportunity to present it
as well as
what biases or dispositions
the various channels have and so i
noticed i mean obviously historically
there are watchdog groups that look at
this sort of thing but
it's all it's like a manual process
right some some poor
human has to watch endless hours of
horrendous cable news that's correct and
the big difference here is that
we have taken of some very manual
painstaking labor
by folks that want to understand what's
being communicated
and had a computer automate a lot of
that labor
[Music]
one of the realizations that that came
out was
an imbalance between male and female
host there's
there's a lot more male hosts one thing
i was surprised about was that i mean
fox news has almost
a one-to-one ratio between male hosts
and female hosts
they had by far the best balance on the
host side but on the
on the pundit side they were i think the
worst
that's correct and and one of the the
real uh
the things that we're interested in
doing is that we all have sort of
a narrative about what what's going on
in the world and and this is about
putting
data behind that narrative and and the
conclusion sometimes are quite
interesting
i wanted to talk just a little bit about
the nuts and bolts of how you guys put
this together because one thing i did
not realize
amazon has this facial recognition tool
that you can buy as a service what we
are surfacing to the public are the
results of amazon's celebrity
recognition service api
i'm excited to introduce for you a new
service called amazon recognition video
which does real-time and batch
video analytics we'll detect
objects and faces and scenes it is
a form of doing facial recognition at
scale which has been talked about and
continues to be talked about at length
in the media right now because
it's extremely controversial technology
amazon
can scan your face without your consent
and sell it to the to the government all
without our knowledge correct
yes now on one hand that's what we are
doing we are running
amazon's face recognition software on
every frame of the news
for the last decade but we think that
this is an
application of face recognition where
the potential for harm
is low it is run only on individuals
that have appeared
on cable tv news but we thought that the
the ability to audit what is going on on
the news
was a positive use case but we had to
make a judgment and the judgment we made
was that the
the benefits outweighed the potential
harms one thing
you know i think is worth bringing up
which you guys address
the facial recognition it does way
better on
kind of like white guys than it does on
females and and
it also has some struggles on gender
especially for people who
you know might identify in in different
ways is that right i mean it's basically
strongest on like white male pundit than
anything else
most of these services have shown
scientifically that there is bias in
these systems
and so any conclusions that you take
from automated machine learning analysis
uh need to be inspected very carefully
to determine if that bias is playing a
factor in
in the results our goal is
is to create interesting new
capabilities
tools for analysts or creators tools for
artists if it's an entertainment
and so like any any tool builder like
you want to use the best tool for the
job
and when ai provides new opportunities
and is the right tool for the job by all
means we should use it
but we also look at it with some
skepticism in that
if we go back to the tennis project that
we talked about earlier
shoot most of the reason why that looks
so good is because we took human
knowledge of how tennis works
and encoded it in the computer and we
use the ai to kind of fill in the gaps
but the main knowledge is still human
and i actually think when people stop
doing that and rely completely on data
or completely on ai to build systems
that's that's where stuff starts getting
going wrong you know for for better or
for worse computing has gotten very very
powerful in the last
decade and and there are amazing things
that we can do with that power
and there are significant concerns and
significant issues that that
power is bringing to bear on all of
society yeah
there's a lot of responsibility to think
very thoughtfully about what we are
doing and why
you